hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and today is monday
november 2nd 2020 and it's going to be a
very interesting week obviously we got
the election on tuesday we got a fed
meeting happening
on beginning on wednesday you've got
the unemployment number coming out on
friday and you got some other
earnings coming out this week as well
and you know
everyone is sort of bracing for this
very volatile time in the market you
know um you know a lot of brokers have
done you know what i can say it's kind
of sensible what they did is you know
they they've
put their margins they've set their
margins to the exchange
uh levels as opposed to letting people
trade with just 500
trading in e-mini or nasdaq um you know
that that will keep some of these uh
sort of weak traders out of the market
and
you know over the weekend i was watching
some youtube
and i see a lot of these youtube traders
saying oh you know i can't trade this
week because
because it's gonna be more volatile well
you know honestly i don't know where
they've been the last uh the last six
months
um you know prior to this year
you know when vixx is trading in the 20s
everyone would always oh my gosh fix is
so high
now if the vix trades in to the the 20
level
you know that's that's considered low so
you know it's it's
going to be an interesting day or
interesting week i think uh for the
markets but you know what
that doesn't mean that that order flow
isn't going to
you know reseed and the market's just
going to dry up you know volumes today
have been
pretty normal um you know for example
this is the
order flow from this morning on the cash
open here's the cash open
and you can see the market uh you sort
of went sideways sold off and then it
rallied from
a swing low here around 8 46 this
morning at 32 89
and a quarter now you know recently
we've
released an upgraded version of the
order flows trader software because
like i said you know over the last year
basically
we've been seeing increased volatility
in the market
and with increased volatility you know
order flow is you're seeing moves not
just in the order flow
but you know in in all the markets um
where they move seem a little bit
exaggerated
and so we've sort of refined some of the
tools that we already have
in the order flows trader and we added a
few more tools like value area
extended value area order flow
sequencing
poc slingshot the you know
new ways to look at market imbalances
looking for market sweeps but this
morning
you know there was some nice signs here
in the order flow just after the cache
opened
with some of the newer tools that that
we released in the order flows trader
and you can see this red area this is
what we call an extended value area this
is a bearish sign
in the value area right also we have
what we call poc slingshot right right
here this is a bearish slingshot this is
a bearish poc right here
we have order flow sequencing which is
bearish right here this
these magenta areas in the bars right
you see another
bearish value area right here then we
get down to that swing low at 89 and a
quarter
and what do we see we see a bullish a
bullish
value area here a bullish eva we're
seeing bullish order flow sequencing
and the market rallied up right rallied
all the way up to
new highs of the day it was interesting
you know we got up to these highs of the
day
why didn't we go any higher right why
didn't we take out these stops that were
presumably just passed up here at the
high of the day market wasn't interested
we got a divergence
right then the market just went sideways
sideways sideways sideways
from 9 20 all the way up until it
started selling off here at uh just
after 9 30.
but in the sideways activity
there is signs in the overflow that it's
market is kind of weak and
is getting ready you know to show some
bearish signs we see a bearish order
flow sequencing here
well at the high of the day we do have a
divergence right up here we got the
negative delta
at the high of the day we got a single
print we got some market exhaustion up
there
we've got a bearish a bearish value area
right here that's this red area
and another new tool that we created is
is a sign looking for market weakness
either
weaknesses coming into the market after
the markets rallied
or after the market sold off weakness
near the low the day meaning
the selling pressure has gotten weak and
what happens
next bar after you have the divergence
the bearish overflow sequencing the
bearish value area the market weakness
in the next bar you've also got
another bearish order flow sequencing
and the market starts moving down
from the 15 16 area all the way down
to you know the o203 area where it just
starts to go sideways
you know that's a that's a 10 point move
in about 15 minutes
on basically a one minute chart on the
e-minis is the e-mini one-minute chart
so you know even though you know the
people are saying oh the market's going
to be extremely volatile
or you know there's not going to be as
much liquidity there
right now the market's trading pretty
normal right it's following what's
happening in the order flow
pretty well right that's what the order
flows traders doing is it's helping you
analyze what's happening here in the
order flow and telling you if it's
bullish or bearish
right now up here just after that high
was made it's telling you
it's bearish order flow that's coming
into this market right and if you know
the order flows bearish you know it's
going to
give you especially at the high of the
day if you know the order flows bearish
at the high of the day
you know it's going to give you a
potential move ideally down to the low
of the day but at least you know a move
away
down into the day's value area so
as you saw that was a quick 10 point
move down and even earlier right after
the cash open right after the
basically after the trading day started
in terms of cash
markets started selling off but then it
got down to this low here at 89 and a
quarter
and the signs in the order flow turned
bearish sorry bullish right it was
bearish just after the cash opened
then 15 minutes later it turns bearish
and the market rallies all the way up to
those new highs where the order flow
turned
bearish so you know
if uh like i said
you don't have to trade every single day
you know i said you know this week is is
a strange week with the election
with uh fed with some earnings obviously
with the employment numbers coming out
at the end of the week
but you know pick your spots and you
know order flow allows you to
pick your spots in the market so that
you know you can make good trading
decisions
right that's why we created the order
flows traders because
we want to give traders a tool that's
going to help them better understand
what's happening in the order flow so if
you're interested
in learning more about order flow click
on the link below in the description
it's orderflows.com
off three and because order flow gets
you as close to what's happening in the
market as possible
right you're seeing what's being traded
on the bid what's being traded on the
offer
so again you know this week is is going
to be a very
interesting week but you know don't
necessarily abandon
it you know if you see something
interesting um you know you can get some
really nice moves i think so
thanks for watching this video and you
know enjoy the rest of the
trading week bye